bonsoir je ne sais pas vous mais moi
une petite confidence pas facile de
passer après neuf explorateurs home est
aussi brion les 20 que les autres biens
quand on pense aux explorateurs ben
généralement on imagine des gens avec
des chapeaux en cuir ou alors de grands
bateaux ou alors des navettes spatiales
ce soir je vais vous parler d'une autre
sorte d'exploration celle du monde
microscopique des êtres vivants infinie
bon petit petit par leur taille mais
grand par leur importance aussi bien
pour l'homme que pour son environnement
de nombreux travaux de recherche ont
démontré leur intérêt pour résoudre
certains problèmes qui se posent de nos
jours un autre société
nous allons découvrir ensemble notamment
les capacités insoupçonnées de certains
champignons qui vivent cachés dans le
sol sous sol qui a été longtemps
considéré comme un simple support ou les
plantes sont racines épuise les éléments
nutritifs indispensables à leur
développement est en réalité un
fantastique réservoir d'organismes
vivants tant en terme de biodiversité
qu'en termes de densité si je
m'intéresse uniquement aux champignons
et bien d'un g de champignons on peut
trouver environ 100000 champignons
différents ce qui correspond environ à 3
5 tonnes par hectare il existe
différents types de champignons les plus
connus sont les plus visibles pourtant
des chapeaux diverses et variées qu'on
rencontre dans les forêts généralement
et qu'on aime bien cueillir en tout cas
certains d'entre eux eh bien ça ne sera
pas cela qui vont faire
l'objet de mon intervention aujourd'hui
vous allez me dire mais il y en a
d'autres qui ne portent pas de
champignons de deux chapeaux qui sont
microscopiques mais qu'on connaît bien
et pour cause ils envahissent nos
aliments déconne a le dos tourné il
s'agit des fameux moisissures 500 pas
non plus cela qui vous m'intéressez ce
soir
aujourd'hui les champignons auquel je
m'intéresse font partie d'une famille
qui échappent à leur gare car ils vivent
sous nos pieds dans le sol et peuvent
s'étendre sur des mètres voire des
kilomètres et il se présente beaucoup
plus sous forme de filament que sous
forme d'une tige et d'un chapeau il
s'agit des champignons mycorhiziens
mycorhiziens est un terme qui vient du
grec nico qui veut dire champignons et
risa qui veut dire racines en effet ce
sont des champignons qui vivent en
association avec les racines des plantes
je vais vous parler d'une seule famille
de ce champignon mycorhizien c'est ce
qu'on appelle les plus ré la plus
répondu environ 90% des plantes
terrestres connues que vous voyez tous
les jours vive en réalité avec ce type
de champignons c'est ce qu'on appelle
les champignons mycorhiziens arbus kull
vous allez me dire qu'est ce que c'est
que ce terme barbare encore d'art
bascule ce simple ce sont des
champignons qu'on appelle ainsi parce
que tout simplement ils forment à
l'intérieur des cellules des plantes des
structures sous forme d'arbustes que
vous voyez là et qui permettent les
échanges de nutriments entre la plante
et le champignon ce sont des champignons
microscopiques qui sont apparus il ya
très très longtemps il y en a environ
460 millions d'années et qu'on trouve
dans tous les environnements naturels
même les plus hostiles je dirais que
c'est même là qu'ils deviennent plus
intéressants pour la plante
ce sont des champignons qui ressemble
à quoi alors si ce n'est pas ce qu'on
connaît sont ceux qu'on voit tous les
jours si on déterre une plante on peut
pas réellement voir au niveau de ses
racines ses champignons mais si on prend
le soin de les observer son microscope
on verra la chose suivante les racines
bien sûr et entre les racines on aura un
réseau de fins filaments aux cheveux
très qui qu'on appelle le mycélium qui
constitue un genre de d'extension à
cette racine et qu'ils vont jouer un
rôle dans le prélèvement des nutriments
à partir du sol mais aussi dans la
formation de ce qu'on appelle des sports
qui ne sont autres que les structures de
reproduction de ce type de champignons
alors ce qui est plus intéressant c'est
que c'est ce champignon et cette plante
s'associent pour former ce qu'on appelle
une symbiose à bénéfice réciproque
autrement dit ces deux partenaires
entretiennent en quelque sorte un
rapport gagnant-gagnant pour une
meilleure vie et en l'occurrence la
plante va fournir les sucres aux
champignons et en échange le champignon
lui va améliorer sa lutherie sion en eau
mais aussi en minéraux et en fait ceci
est possible car ce sont pignon va
explorer un volume de sol eu mille fois
supérieur par rapport à une racine seul
de ce bénéfice alimentaire ce bénéfice
alimentaire en réalité va permettre une
meilleure croissance de la plante et par
caen par conséquent une meilleure
résistance au stress environnementaux
c'est à dire à toutes les agressions du
milieu extérieur est justement de ses
nombreux avantages vont découler un
certain nombre d'applications de ces
champignons pour l'homme mais aussi pour
cent en environnement il faut savoir que
c'est pour cette raison que ces
champignons sont considérés aujourd'hui
à l'heure du développement durable comme
des acteurs clés des services que la
nature peut rendre à la société humaine
c'est ce qu'on appelle les services éco
systémiques
alors quelques exemples de ses services
que ces champignons peuvent rendre à la
plante et indirectement à l'homme
parmi les applications potentielles
émergentes actuellement en 1 par exemple
l'utilisation de ces unions en tant que
bio fertilisants ou alors en tant qu
agent biologique de lutte contre les
maladies des plantes ce qui va permettre
de réduire l'usagé des engrais chimiques
mais aussi des pesticides en agriculture
ce qui est une application hyper
importante actuellement une deuxième
application peut avoir une autre
utilisation inattendue cette fois ci
dans le domaine de la réhabilitation des
sols pollués on peut les utiliser en
tant qu'agent bio des pollueurs cette
dernière application potentielle fait
partie des activités de recherche de
notre laboratoire à l'université du
littoral côte d'opale
alors pourquoi on s'intéresse à ce sujet
parce que vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
que cette problématique touche de près
notre région qui est malheureusement la
deuxième région la plus polluée en
france et ceci du fait de son lourd
passé industriel
alors vous avez certainement déjà
entendu parler du risque pour que
présentent pour la santé la pollution de
l'air la pollution de l'eau mais elle
peut ou pas du tout de la pollution du
sol et pourtant on est tous concernés
puisqu'on peut y être exposé de
différentes façons soit de façon directe
50 cern plus particulièrement les
enfants mais aussi les agriculteurs qui
sont amenés à manipuler le sol mais
aussi de façon indirecte via les envols
de poussières via les contamination des
eaux ou alors de transfert vers les
produits alimentaires comme par exemple
la consommation des fruits et légumes
cultivés sur des sols pollués ou alors
tout simplement la viande provenant
d'animaux capturée sur ces soldes donc
on comprend bien que cette pollution
pose un sérieux problème de santé
publique mais aussi environnemental
c'est pourquoi
la question de la remédiation des sols
de la dépollution des sols est devenu
aujourd'hui une priorité aussi bien pour
les pouvoirs publics mais aussi pour les
scientifiques alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que jusqu'aujourd'hui
nos jours en fait les méthodes qui sont
utilisées pour dépolluer les sols sont
principalement des méthodes physiques et
chimiques consistant par exemple en un
traitement thermique ou alors on est
lavage avec des solvants des sols
excavées
malheureusement cette méthode bien
qu'elle soit
rapide elle présente deux inconvénients
majeurs
d'abord elles sont très coûteuses et
surtout elles détruisent toute forme de
vie au niveau du sol générant un
matériau inerte or le sol est une
ressource limitée non renouvelables
qu'on se doit de préserver parmi les
méthodes de dépollution qui sont donc
respectueuse de l'environnement eh bien
on peut voir ce qu'on appelle la
phytoremédiation alors la
phytoremédiation c'est quoi c'est une
méthode douce de dépollution des sols
qui est basée sur la capitale
l'utilisation de la capacité naturelle
des plantes à éliminer les polluants
soit par immobilisation par dégradation
ou alors par extraction simplement alors
cette méthode présente beaucoup
davantage contrairement aux méthodes
physico chimiques elle est à la fois
écologiques économiques applicables sur
de grandes surfaces et surtout préserve
la qualité du solde la phytoremédiation
donc d'ailleurs elle fait partie
des actions prioritaires du grenelle de
l'environnement
son adéquation avec le développement
durable l'avis de remédiation a commencé
à être étudié en france dans les années
90 et l'idée de rajouter un engrais
biologiques à base de ces champignons
mycorhiziens harvey skull a commencé à
se développer uniquement ces digues en
parle
on parle alors de la phytoremédiation
assisté ou aidés par les champignons
mycorhiziens vous allez me dire comment
des champignons peuvent aider une plante
à dépolluer les sols et bien ils vont
augmenter sa capacité à dépolluer les
sols en la protégeant contre la toxicité
des polluants qui se trouve dans le sol
mais aussi en stimulant la flore
microbienne qui se trouve dans le sol
qui elle va prendre en charge les
polluants
plusieurs plantes sont connus pour leur
capacité de phytoremédiation on peut
citer à titre d'exemple quelques
herbacée tels que le riz gras la luzerne
trèfle quelques graminées telles que le
blé le maïs et le miscanthus ce dernier
étant plus à la mode il est en vogue
actuellement c'est ce qu'on appelle
communément l'herbe à éléphant et on a
également quelques arbres tels que le
peuplier et le sol les po lyon donc
traitée par phytoremédiation sont
principalement issus de l'activité des
activités humaines ils peuvent être soit
organiques tels que les hydrocarbures
les pesticides les solvants ou alors
inorganiques telles que les métaux
lourds
alors vous allez me dire oui c'est bien
mais on est la recherche actuellement en
france dans ce domaine et bien la
recherche dans ce domaine c'est à dire
en phytoremédiation est au stade
expérimental
c'est plus exactement au stade de
démonstration c'est à dire qu'on
commence à sortir des laboratoires pour
tester et valider ses méthodologies sur
le terrain directement plusieurs équipes
de recherche travaillent dans ce domaine
et donc en s'appuyant
sur un réseau qui regroupe plusieurs
sites ateliers ou sur lesquels sont
menées des expériences grandeur nature
visant à déterminer des solutions
pratiques pour dépolluer les sols il
s'agit du réseau sapphire side ateliers
français pour l'innovation et la
recherche
actuellement il comporte sept sites dans
200 situé dans le nord c'est donc c'est
ainsi que notre équipe accède à certains
de ces sites ateliers dont 3 que vous
connaissez probablement puisque ils sont
connus pour leur contamination
vous avez le site de metaleurop
qui est ainsi donc ici tu es qui est
située entre douai et lens et qui
correspond à au secteur de l'ancien
bassin minier du nord-pas-de-calais
alors celui là est contaminée fortement
contaminée par les métaux lourds
notamment le plomb le 5 et le cadmium
issus d'anciennes industries
métallurgiques nous avons également le
site de l'union qui lui donc est situé à
cheval sur tourcoing wattrelos et
roubaix et qui est une friche
industrielle en milieu urbain contaminés
par plusieurs polluants dont les
hydrocarbures majoritairement et enfin
on a un troisième site qui est le site
d'alloin qui fait pas partie du réseau
saphir et qui est contaminée qui se
trouve à 20 km de l'île à peu près et
qui est contaminée par des dioxines
provenant de rejet d'un ancien
l'incinérateur d'effectuer défectueux
qui est resté en activité pendant une
trentaine d'années alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que sur l'ensemble de ses
sites atelier des recherches sur les
performances de cette phytoremédiation
assisté par les champignons mycorhiziens
sont en cours actuellement les résultats
obtenus sont plutôt encourageants et
prometteurs
bon nous nous sommes arrivés maintenant
au terme de ce petit voyage exploratoire
au coeur d champignon microscopique du
sol mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
pour les joueurs ce n'est que le début
d'un long voyage visons à exploiter
cette ressource naturelle donc vivante
qui existe d'ailleurs depuis des
centaines de millions d'années pour
résoudre certains problèmes
environnementaux actuels merci pour
votre attention